- I'm here at the Beijing Winter Olympics
and these ATM machines just caught my eye.
They are not just normal ATM machines
that allow you to
deposit or withdraw cash.
They also let international visitors
and participants to the Games
to exchange their foreign bank bills
into the that digital yuan.
(gentle futuristic music)
Let's just try it out.
I have near when me a $20 bill.
(speaking Chinese)
So now I'm going to insert this $20 bill.
- [ATM] Please wait.
Please take away e-CNY.
- [Jing] Now I have a card
with the equivalent amount
of $20 of e-CNY with me on this card.
(pensive music)
- [Woman] You can go to
almost every point of sales
inside the Olympics bubble.
We have the dining halls and
then the merchandise stores.
You can use the e-CNY physical card
to pay for all of these things.
- So I just found a coffee shop here.
I just ordered an Americano.
Okay, and I'm tapping the card.
And we're done.
Now I have my first coffee,
paid with the e-CNY.
(pensive music)
So far, the digital yuan
has failed to resonate.
I've spoken to a number of
foreign Games participants.
All of them either say they
do not intend to use the e-CNY
or some of them even haven't heard of it.
(pensive music)
The near-term goal for the e-CNY
is to popularize it within China,
but so far this has met some challenges.
First is that the e-CNY
is facing competition
from other entrenched
mobile payment platforms.
Another reason is the privacy,
because it is possible that
every transaction you make
can be seen and be visible to authorities.
But China is the way ahead
in the development of the digital currency
compared to other
countries, including the US,
which is considering
its own digital dollar.